IMPRESSIABLD.
COUNTRY, HIS RESPONSIB
HIS OWN ACTIOND HI
CHOICES.
>> JOINGOM, VICE CIRF
THE EXHIBIT COMMITTEE REPUBLICAN
YOUR YOU BELIEVE
YOUR COMMITTEE SUCCESSFULL
CASE
COMMTE S
HAS ND LL, I THINK THEMI
GATHEREDREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WE'RE NOFIAY
'S CLEAR, IF YLOOKCA OPINIONAT T
TRUMP COTE LEASTCRIM
E D YET AS A
R THGOCRERRALS.
THERN WE'VE SEEN  SERIOUST AN
RTE DE.
T AT LAID OUT
TH THESE HEARINGS IN TERMSF
COTHE DEPARTMEO DOOR
STATE ANCEDID INE  TO VIOLATE TA
- EVER ONEREALWITH HIM TF AND S
IOS WERE
PUBLICAN ON TH BELIEVETHMMD
WH'SON YOU THINK DONALD TRUMP B
THT DONALD
E VIOLATION OF THAT HENG
IS THE MOSSES MISCONDUCT
OF ANYE HISTORY
AT, AS ID,
TEE HAS NODED
ET WE'LL MAK
CRIMIN.
THATOMKE VERY
AHE DEPARTMENNLIS WHAT WE SEEUR
N RICAN STORY.
BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
ES IS UNT R FUR
OFFICE.ANY MAN WHO WOUL
THEMSELVES - WOMAN WHO WOULD
CONDES IN THWADIINEMPTING TO OVN
ELECTION AND STA PUS
VEN TH.  QORS HAVE EN OPENEANK E
PAT POE AGREED TTOE TEE.T ON YO
S YOU MUST WAN
FROM I MONTHS?
E  AY
ATLKG L MEMBERS OF THE PRESIDENS
CABINET.
WE ANTICAT
F .Y VI AND
ONDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE SECREIC
INFORMATION FROM THEM.T'D I WOUL
PARTICULAR AFTER ON'S TESTIMONY
NUMBER OLE COME FORWARD.
CECIPOLLONE, T SUE ISSUED TD
SERVICF URITY SAYS T WOULDAY'SOE
IGATIVE
OPENING A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATO E
DELIBERATE DESTROYED?
COMMITTED?>>Y DELY TROUBLE
I SAY THAT, U KNOW T
SOMEONE WH
YEARS WAS PROTECTEE OF
SECRET SERI HAVE NDN ME SECRE
SECULARLY THOSE WITH
MYILY ON 9/1E H OF 9/11.H
TREMDOIVIDUA
BUT I ALNO
IN TERMS
E COURSE OTHE  IS DEEPLY
I SO WATCHED
R G LAEETRAFFIC, LISTENED TO E E
AN VICE
PRESIDWAAN
SERVICE THAT DMEY S
E BOTTOM OF.T THE INFORMATION T
SUCLARENCE
THASEPEATEDLY TAFF MAR
THEM ABOUT EFFORTSERTURN  THEORN
THE 2020 ELECTIORESULTS, NOT OR
>> WE ARTHE COMMITTEH COWE HOPG
TO CONTEMPLATE SUBPOENA HE
DOES NOT.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T GET TO
WHLUNTWE'VE CERTAINLY SPOKEN WI
Y SITUATN TERM
SCUSSIG
THAT'VIOD.T' F
SPEA AND, AS I SAIPE D
>> YOU CAL FORE RULE O AP SER S
CONGRESS B TO
COUBPOEN
YOUREENN HE PLANS
.
NKONY T.ERING AS TO WHY SOY
I' BA
FORMER TRU HOUSEAL BECAUSE HE CM
THESE FAR
RIGHT MILI WITH S
>> I THINK IT'S VERYARHAT
STEVON HAS I
INFORMATION THATHE COMMITTEE
NE.
YOU CAN TELL THAT IN AR CLUDINGY
THURSDAY WHERENG E0
DORUMP WAS PINAR MATTER WHATTHET
OMMITTEE
A SUBPOENAFTER
LTIPLE
TIMES, AND HE SIMPLY REFUSEDLY
T
MP
HAS EN CCTHELD IN CONTEMPT AND
N OBLIGATIONASS AMERICANWI
CONGRESS.MAONI THSAID,
CLEARLY WHEN HE WAS O
R RYE
PREDICTIONS ABOUT WHAT WOULDHAP
SAYING PUBLICLY ABOUT ENTS OUSA
DENIERS ARE
WINNINACROSSER
ARIZ
HOU THAT
WAS JUST THE ANT IN
FUTURE, SOMEONE   STEAL ATION?
WITH RESPECT TO DONALD T,  CAN E
CLOSE TO OVA AGAIN
HIS DETRNGGHHRUA RCY, HIS TO HIF
N,HET TO WHE BETRAYINGL PATIF IW
RUNNIN ILD SAY I, THCANDIDATES O